and the electoral commission of zambia
this is it
have released the final election in an
address to the nation president ed
galungu accepted he lost last week's
election to opposition leader hakainde
chilema
hi comply
with the consumer provisions
for a peaceful
transition of power
i would therefore like to congratulate
my brother
the president-elect
his excellency in sahaja yoga
for becoming the seventh
republican president
he chilema says one of his priorities
will be tackling zambia's debt crisis
the country owes more than 12 billion
dollars to external companies and
lenders our message to lenders is very
simple
come to the table
the debt we have is unsustainable
some of it was accrued
wrongly
incompetently
but
we are decent people we are decent team
[Music]
he chilema defeated lungu by more than a
million votes in his sixth attempt at
winning the presidency it's the third
time power has shifted peacefully from a
governing party to the opposition since
zambia gained its independence from
britain in 1964.
president edgar lungu was criticized for
alleged human rights abuses massive
unemployment and corruption
president-elect hakayinde hichleima now
has to manage expectations many zambians
want him to do things differently
[Music]
the president-elect is promising to turn
around the country's fortunes saying his
five-year term in office will be a new
chapter for zambia now i mean he'll wait
to see if he will deliver on his
promises
[Music]
al jazeera